[Applaudissements]
l'école est là le prof qui date est
surtaxée 6 et hulene contrôle de maths
je vois là une non je n'ai pas voir
combien de fois ça m'arrive en contrôle
sur toi aussi tu nies en fait tous les
énoncés
je regarde la une comme ça tu fais un an
là une déjà non aussi je n'ai pas
troisième tour gardes tu fais troisième
as tu vois un chiffre non on fait quand
tu vois la 4 et tu vois tu en fait t'as
rien de tout contrôler c'est quand même
[Rires]
pas soit la piste du petit un passereau
sylla a d'ailleurs rien derrière déjà
quitté pas non mais tu vois que des u7
hongroise de contrôle mais oui mais je
ne dormais pas de la nîmoise se régler
les contrôles ou tu sais que tu sais
c'était une banane flambée
non mais c'était avant je veux que votre
cerveau et vous alors ça doit que
l'histoire de votre vie non ce qui est
flippant secte il lit les feuilles de
brouillon
ah ouais toi tu le crois que tu es chaud
tu as rempli une demi feuille de
brouillon tu vois les autres étaient un
moment tu te lèves et tu regarde combien
il a dit non plus que toi là à
l'intérieur toujours une femme mais elle
a les cheveux comme at elle écrit dont
elle tenait un moment fait elle regarde
c'est ça
mais
les matches
[Applaudissements]
mais moi mes mains et lève les yeux à la
désinformation
mais moi qu'est ce que je faisais à la
fin je remplissais débrouille j'écrivais
des joueurs de foot sur ma vie
j'écrivais n'importe quoi là pour faire
du stylet choix et georges je sortais
laquelle je vais les origines et dans
l'ambiance
là c'était 4x plus j'ai choisi de
contrôler c'est chelou
ah ouais moi c'est du délire à sera moi
je suis explique fois j'en ai moi je
n'ai pas pleuré parce que voilà je
prenais sur moi mais c'est vrai que tu
as fait quoi comme es tu toi moi j'ai
fait le s terminale es économie mon bac
et après après j'ai eu un petit 16 en
espagnol ensuite j'ai fait ce bts
commerce international
j'ai compris que j'étais pas dans le
commerce et surtout pas internationale
et je me suis fait virer je suis devenu
drôle c'est sûr que non eh bien eh bien
vous ne croyez pas si bien dire puisque
je n'ai même pas mon bepc
non
[Musique]
moi quand tu peux y le bepc à 13 ans
j'ai voulu marier pour avoir un diplôme
c'est logique pour un truc tu vois et je
veux gagner tu te marier avec moi avait
dit mais j'ai 13 ans question casse la
terre mon badge au ton on connaît moi
j'étais la fille aînée revente ou sa
tablette pc montre jamais prépa hec près
boîte à fait prêt prêt à chausser
ouais tout ça pour finir dans l'axé vous
avez toutes les trois des cursus
complètement différent pourtant vous
vous retrouvez sur le même projet comme
quoi la vie de foi à m sila